all right this this is something very
different that i'm gonna do and
let me know if you think that that this
is uh interesting for the show and
whether this is instructive as many of
you know
and many people are mad about this i
don't talk about politics with viewers
via email i'm so busy doing the show
that i i can't respond to political
questions via email or engage in that
way
at this point we get about 6 000 emails
comments
tweets facebook posts and the like every
single day
we would need multiple full-time people
if the idea was to sort of like engage
meaningfully with every every comment
but every once in a while if there's
something that i think will be
instructive
i will sort of jump in and uh get
involved
and indeed i received an email yesterday
morning from an anti-vaccine individual
spouting conspiracy theories
and i decided to engage i decided to
actually
let's see where they are getting their
information
how did they come to hold the beliefs
that they have and so i'm protecting
uh her email address and and and last
name
but i am going to go through a
conversation i had via email
with an anti-vaxxer named amy now amy
wrote to me yesterday morning
with the subject a concerned viewer and
amy said
about vaccines just curious how you
could deceive others when it comes to
the covid
and the vaccines i'm well aware that you
know it's all a scam
and the so-called vaccines are causing
deaths now there's there's probably five
things there to look at
uh the idea that i know that it's a scam
what the virus or vaccination
the so-called vaccine refers to people
who say
these aren't actually vaccines causing
deaths refers to people who believe
it is the vaccine causing people to die
rather than covet itself
so there's a lot here but let's let's
get a big picture view of what she's
saying
amy goes on is money that important to
you that you have to go along with this
now no who would even pay me to save the
vaccines
or you know i i really got a vaccine
nobody paid me to do that
nobody's paying me to say that it was
great uh
i i don't even know who would be willing
to give me money to do that
amy goes on people are starting to
despise you
well people have despised me for a long
time that's not that she's right about
that but that's not new
and you don't have to believe me but all
traders involved in this scam
will see a prison cell it's already
mentioned in a couple lawsuits i know of
so keep on with your nonsense and you
will see so i actually decided
to write back to amy and i said
no one has died from the vaccine we will
not spread dangerous propaganda
on our show to which amy wrote me back
very quickly i have proof i
also have proof from cdc documents
we are being played the fact that you
don't even
ask about the proof i have proves
you are involved in this scam so up
until this point the allegation is
because i've not asked her for the proof
i'm part of the scam now i actually
uh want to see where she is getting
these ideas i want to see what documents
what websites what is it that these
anti-vaxx conspiracy folks
are basing their ideas on so i wrote
back okay
send it send me the stuff i want to see
the proof and amy wrote back
first without even addressing the fact
that i've asked for the information
saying you know exactly what's up
there are cdc documents admitting we're
being played
lawsuits filed saying we're being played
mike pompeo was asked one time if covid
was a hoax and he wouldn't answer
now that was for political reasons that
that's not you know mike pompeo is
secretary of state he
he doesn't know anything about
immunology or epidemiology
and she goes on to say as for the fake
vacs why would fauci get caught
faking getting it i have that proof too
this is a conspiracy that
dr fauci pretended to be vaccinated but
that the he wasn't really injected
and then she finishes her email by
saying there's all kinds of death
reports and the list of proof goes on
and on you do know all
this now uh of course i want the proof
now
so i simply wrote back to amy please
send me the documents so i can review
them
lawsuits and documents and now amy says
slowing down her responses a little bit
taking a little more time between
responses amy says
i'll get the info together now however i
feel like this is a trick
because i know how you people work you
all want to know what info we have so
you can scrub it from the internet so
this is interesting first evidence of my
malfeasance was that i didn't ask for
the proof
now it's suspicious that i am asking for
the proof and of course the idea that i
can just have things scrubbed from the
internet
you know we're now going many levels
deep amy says i'm not stupid and i don't
trust anyone
there's no way you don't know this
especially doing what you do while i'm
getting the info
here is the name of one attorney dealing
with a lawsuit reiner rolmick
and a question still is why wouldn't
mike pompeo answer when asked if kovid
was a hoax
why would dr fauci fake getting the
so-called vaccine
there's no way you wouldn't know what's
up
so i wrote back again i'm remaining very
calm
and i just said it's no trick i want to
see the info
amy writes back i'm getting the info
together and like i said reiner
rolmick is one of the attorneys and he
admits
it's fraud again we don't know what is
fraud
little more time goes by amy sends me
another email
i just ran across this about the
inventor of the tests they're using for
kovid
he tells you it can't detect if you're
sick
notice how they remove the video because
it's truth now i don't know what video
she's referring to
but the article she sent has nothing to
do with proof of people dying from the
vaccine
they aren't lawsuit documents it's
merely an article which says
pcr tests can't tell you if you are
actually
ill with something and we know that and
that has nothing to do with covid pcr
tests
are designed to tell you is a particular
signal present in a swab
uh you might physically have some virus
particles in you and you might not
actually be
sick that's not news of any kind and so
i wrote back at this point and i said
amy you said you had proof the vaccine
is killing people
this is an article about testing can you
send the articles you mentioned
about vaccines as well as the lawsuits
and i never heard from amy again
now there are certainly some anti-vaxx
conspiracy theorists
who would have things to send me and if
they
did i would evaluate the sources in the
past they're uh
very disreputable websites you know
natural news type sites and
things like this but this is a great
example
of the types of thinking we're dealing
with where
me wanting the information or not
wanting it both
are part of the conspiracy finding the
videos she's referring to
would be proof of the conspiracy but if
she can't find them
that's proof that someone removed them
in order to cover up
the conspiracy and so i think the
takeaway for me is
obviously you know i this this took an
hour out of my day
it's not plausible to do what it would
this is a retail strategy
to disabuse people of these notions now
because amy ultimately couldn't find any
of the things she said she was going to
send me
did she change her views even probably
not what i did probably didn't even
change her views and this really goes to
the difficulty in dealing with this type
of conspiratorial thinking we've done
interviews with experts on
conspiratorial thinking
and conspiracism and they pointed to the
same thing
let me know what else maybe we can learn
from this but certainly
an illuminating moment in illuminating
just how much of an uphill battle
this is and uh i'd love to hear from you
you can find me
on twitter at deepakman i'm
really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but
helix has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video